hey guys what's up this is andrew for
chainsenses.com so sorry i didn't post
anything for quite some time i was
actually feeling not well i was sick i'm
not sure what i had uh but i can tell
you that in hong kong you don't want to
find out if it's the covered or not
because if it is they simply put you in
quarantine prisons so anyway i feel much
better now so i guess it was nothing too
bad and i'm back guys to make a huge
update on amc so let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so i don't remember when
i did my last update but we have a lot
of things happening here
so the first thing for those who want to
have my daily update it is still
available on discord and even if i'm
sick i'm still gonna post every day an
analysis on gme and on amc so if you
wanna see what i have to say you can
just go and check it out
so
let's go on a daily timeframe first
here we have this fourth corrective wave
i think that we're on a fifth wave that
we're going to the 100 130 area all
right this is my view now in this fifth
wave we're gonna have probably a five
waves move up so we had already some
bearish first signals appearing here so
let me go on the first time frame we had
here you see the magazine going lower so
each time you have a move up you can use
this on any stock any asset it works on
crypto as well anytime you see the macd
going lower and the market making new
highs
okay this
is the first signal of potential
correction to come but sometimes you
have those bearish divergences and the
market is still pushing higher and
higher and higher it's the same thing on
the downside so it's not enough by
itself but it's a first sign and we had
it here so i told you guys we had this
divergence then we went slightly above
and finally we had this evening star
pattern
that was identified two days ago so
basically it's not perfect because the
gap
is actually filled with the tails here
of the candles but you have one candle
like one isolated candle after a huge
bullish trend
that is followed by a gap down and we
had a gap up before the scandal so this
is the evening star once again it's not
perfect because the gaps are filled with
the tails but it's still a bearish
pattern so after that we were expecting
of course some bearish momentum to pick
up and this is what looks to me as the
first corrective wave of this five waves
move up so we are here one two three
four five so it's too early to talk
about the third wave but for now we're
in the second wave so we had this
evening star pattern then if i zoom in a
little bit what happened afterwards of
course was a strong selling pressure
yesterday in the morning session and we
found support in the middle of our
support area so we have identified
support at 45 32 and 39.5
so this is the one that acted as support
you can see the 20 period moving average
acted here very well as support but it
was hard to predict was not perfectly
respected before here we have one clean
reactions so quite hard to use this one
to enter
but still it acted here as support so
right now what is the situation like i
said this morning on my discord uh we
have here a hammer all right so here is
the evening star and now we have a
hammer it means that so basically when
you have the the head of the hammer that
is here and you have the huge tail uh
dance on the downside which means a lot
of bears have been caught so this is
kind of to me canceling the bearish
effect of the evening start that
otherwise could last you know one week
or two weeks so this is a bit coming to
cancel it but it's not as powerful as
the evening star so i would say that the
favor is let's say it's neutral
but
i think we still gonna have a pose so
maybe you know we need to be aware of
the fact that corrective uh waves they
usually develop in abc so we had a
so maybe it's a b and we're gonna have a
c so the c wave doesn't need to go below
wave a it can be a flat all right so it
will depend how high we come back but
for me as long as we are below 48 we are
still in this corrective phase so once
again
i'm very convinced that once it's
finished we're gonna have even stronger
wave starting but for now i don't have
the signals that the second wave is
complete once again if we close above 48
it would be a first good signal that
maybe this correction is already
complete but i would like to see if you
see the bullish wave it lasts around one
month so would be surprised to have a
correction of only three days usually if
you have one month of bullish
development you need to have at least
one week of correction and once again it
doesn't need to go deeper it only needs
to last maybe a bit longer so i think
that they're going to be many
opportunities here in the coming week to
enter this trade if you are still not in
there so now let's check quickly the
synthetic shock interest on amc so here
we were checking cents by the way we
have this one in our option book in our
live training portfolios on discord so
very quickly uh for those who are
interested to know what we do there we
are trying different strategies based on
breakouts mostly on momentum eliot way
fibonacci and we are gonna record every
trade we do and see what is giving us
the best results so roughly we have a
growth target of five percent uh every
month so let's see if we manage uh to do
this but this is what we are trying to
achieve there so let's go back to amc so
this is something we pay attention a lot
all right for every trade we take we
check this
because the option market is giving you
a lot of information so here we are at
so the maximum synthetic shot is 21
percent uh so it didn't move uh since
last time we have checked it we can
check here amc okay so on the 27th of
august the max was 22 all right so we
are slightly below but it's roughly the
same okay i'm going to record what is
happening up now i added this one for
this month so let's see where this is
coming from we have the septem september
which is a quarterly uh expiry so which
is a big one some monthly and quarterly
september expiry in two days uh so let's
see where do we have a lot of options
okay okay so basically 40 45 50 55 so we
are right now around 45
so what we are here playing paying
attention to is those options that are
out of the money but can certainly uh
get back in the money because there are
going to cause a lot of troubles to
market makers so we have here one you
see 30 delta so this one is dying this
one is already dead all right the 55
strike call for the 17th of september
maturity
uh has a delta of 15
which means that if suddenly we go above
55 on the expiry day market makers we
need to buy 85
of the number of options that we have
here on this strike and you have around
five million options here and this is
true for this strike and this strike as
well so i would say that around 45 there
is no big activity okay we have only
this one with 20 000 option which is not
that much we have 3 million in total for
the strike but on september we only have
around 2 million and you can see that
it's bigger for the more upside strikes
i would say that if we stay around 45
nothing much would happen but if
suddenly we start to trade above 50 or
55 we might have some crazy moves
happening on the expiry day and once
again because of those very out of the
money options where we have a
very substantial amount of open interest
so guys that's it for me i hope you
enjoyed this video i will i will make
one for jme today i will also make some
videos where we explain every trade we
do on our live training portfolio so
this is gonna be only for our platinum
members so that you guys can follow what
we do we're gonna post this very soon uh
in the discord or maybe private on
youtube we're gonna see so
if you did enjoy this video please don't
forget guys to click on the sub like and
bell button so you're gonna be the first
to know when i upload anything new and
stay close to shore i'll see you guys